my fellow good and decent and fine and
righteous americans
i want to thank you from the bottom of
my heart for coming out today and
standing here
for hours because you stand for america
you say yes to freedom and no to the
ground zero mosque
thank you it's all you a couple of
things first when you exit you exit back
let me warn you of something listen to
mommy okay
there are infiltrators there are
agitators there are people that are
looking to get you on video in an ugly
moment please trust me on this this is
what i do i watch the stuff
do not give them any ammunition you know
who you are you know that you're
righteous do not give them the
opportunity to deride this fine and
honorable effort remember what i'm
saying they're looking to catch you
don't give it to them and i'm going to
just turn over the speaker to my
colleague my partner
and my fellow anti-muslim islamophobic
racist bigot
roberts
and so we come to the end of this and
what have we done we have strengthened
our resolve
we are never going to give up
the political elites are out of touch
with the will of the people
and that means the political elites are
going to have to give way
and there will never be a mosque at
ground zero
never
thank you very much and god bless you
watch atlas shrugs and jihad watch for
the next rally we will be calling upon
you each one of you is a soldier we need
you now is the time thank you
and please remember the police have
asked us if you could exit through the
back
back this way i apologize to all the
people in the front for that exit
through the back
oh beautiful
proved
in
liberating strife
who more themselves
nobleness
and you know when i was in school we
should sing it something like this
listen here
waves of grain
majesties
sweet
america
yes he
you know
i wish i had somebody say this
is
you